hospitals across the Gaza Street are
overwhelmed with Israel's UNR lanting
attacks dozens more keep arriving there
are not enough rooms for the patients
and no space in the MS for the death in
Northern Gaza Kamal adan's Hospital
floor is now where Medics have to treat
the wounded survivors say there is
nowhere to
go my family and I were sitting at home
unsuspecting all of a sudden we were hit
by a missile the roof collapsed and it
turned totally dark we are peaceful
civilians sitting at home what can we do
where can we go do you want to push us
to siai it's a residential area no
militants in the
area in the Taz residential Square
dozens are still under the rubble
Israeli heavy bombardment level the area
the attack goes on while people use
their bare hands to recover the bodies
of their loved ones from under the
rubble no civil defense no ambulance
they say the outside world has deserted
them you see for yourselves the whole
world abandoned us only God is our rock
this building alone had more than 50
persons inside the same in that one and
that one also those are my flesh and
blood you see for yourself to God Only
We
complain the Arab and Muslim countries
turn their back on us
all those were killed were innocent
families women and
children scared and horrified this boy
doesn't know yet how many of his family
members have been
killed we were all sitting in that room
all of a sudden a missile hit the
house we crawled out from under the
ruins we are using our bare hands to
reach our families under the rebel there
is no help coming to us
here with Israel expanding his operation
deeper into Gaza there is no sign of the
war stopping anytime
soon the violence inflicted on
Palestinians has already killed more
than 12,000
people 5,000 of them
children on Saturday Medics evacuated
hundreds of patients from gaza's largest
hospital alifa they said Israel forced
them to leave
the World Health Organization is now
preparing to move nearly 300 patients
and staff to Naser Hospital in southern
Gaza but it too exceeded its maximum
capacity weeks ago R Sardar Al jaer